tell the truth how do you know truth
don't the people
are you can't trust somebody if you
don't know them you can't trust me
obviously when I you know preach what
I'm preaching it's on behal of God but
you don't know you can't trust them can
you you can't say BN
this then anyone can say anything and
everyone's right the truth can't be m
one
we have to think our hearts what is the
truth we got our religion for
Ser except Jesus as
God that's God not
everything so Jesus Is God he must know
everything as does he know
everything in the Bible you go to show
you
something go to
mark2 Jesus
so
here 13:32 yeah Jesus Jesus clearly said
know hour
[Music]
here of the
day but of the
day and the hour no one
knows not even the as is in the Heaven
nor the son but only the father so you
believe Jesus is not the father is the
son Jesus said only the father knows the
hour in the day of judgment when it's
going to happen day of Resurrection so
if Jesus doesn't know the hour can be
that the only answer that a Christian
can give you they said no here he was
speaking as a man not as God but even
this one cannot be respond to the
argument I'm bringing to the table you
know why because as good the
father even
ases as he's the son and Jesus in the
Bible clearly explicitly negated the
knowledge of the hour from everyone
except the father even the Holy Spirit
do know the hour okay and for example
does God have a
God so if Jesus Is God you should have
no God but in the Bible Jesus he said
I'm going to my God and your God so my
father and your father so Jesus again
have a God how can he be a God that
doesn't make any sense and you know in
the Quran Allah tell us that about Jesus
and Mary both used to
eat why because this is not God's nature
God is
self-sufficient God is not in need of
nothing God is not in need of food you
know this human nature so there's many
passages in the Bible you can see be
good and that's what I say to her that
you may go back to the priest or the
local preer close to but you need to use
you know your natural B to understand
response is actually valid is it
plausible oh yeah we believe God is you
know all non at all times but just
humbled himself for like a couple
minutes can you not see like you just
agreed that God is all non at all times
then you said it effec Paradox it's a
paradox I know I know I'm just giving
you example sorry I just wanted you to
like you don't believe
sorry how
he yeah so if he was fully human so when
he say he doesn't hour which part he has
not hour as good or as
human so so that's a paradox as well cuz
you know there called impossible it's
it's impossible to happen
for example to say God exist and not
exist at the same time this has nothing
to do with God's power go and and guess
this goes and guess God's nature God's
nature to have perfect life so if God
has no life have no has no life he
cannot be the same God it's impossible
to same to be the same God when we say
he cannot be doesn't mean doesn't have
the power it means it's impossible which
doesn't make any sense because having no
life is deficiency so to say God is so
powerful he can become deficient that's
not powerful it's deficiency not power
you understand deficiency goes and get
one of the attribute of God's power or
God Essence which is perfect life so the
Christians what they doing they they
they don't not differentiate between
what God is and what God does what we
talking about here is what God does we
talking about what God is from from
God's Perfection to have a perfect life
from God's Perfection to have a perfect
Knowledge from God's Perfection to be
self-sufficient all the time so tell CA
able to all things to become imperfect
but you got you are going against God to
be perfect imperfect doesn't not make
God perfect you understand so so this
that how Satan deceive many Christians
by making them believe something doesn't
make any sense and thinking that you are
reting God because if you I believe the
Christians are restricting God CU if God
become
imperfect he been
restricted cuz imperfection go and get
God's Perfection So when you say what
talking about what God is if you tell me
Jesus was God and the same time that is
a paradox because if God become a man he
has to go his own nature which is being
God because to be a man you have to be
imperfect to be a man Jesus is imperfect
in knowledge
he was born
ignorance he had to be taught by Jewish
rabbis imagine God someone teaching
God teaches
andh me far away Allah from this evil
attribute which has been attribute to
him because imperfection you with me so
that's why we in the Quran Allah
mean Allah is far away from any
imperfection who is Allah the Lord of
The Lord of perfect might you know so
Allah is far away what people attribute
to from deficiency one of them have a
son one of them that became human being
you have your own intellect that's why
what we're talking about here we're not
talking about some deep issues we're
talking about the most basic concept of
God I'm not tell I'm not telling you how
God look you don't know you know so what
we talking about here we're talking
about things which we know based upon
scripture about God to be perfect
likewise our s is in our natural
creation so if you really want to
believe in Jesus the way Jesus want to
believe in it is by by following Islam
not Paul you follow Paul not
Jesus do you know that about
islook yeah I'll give you example
example of that Paul he said there's no
circumcision anymore Jesus was
circumcised Paul when the young boy
asked Jesus how to enter the Kingdom of
Heaven Jesus said to him to keep the
Commandments of God what was Paul's
answer Paul's answer was is to believe
in Jesus died for your sins it's about
faith it's not about the law anymore
that's what Jesus teaching you know
that's why pa had a problem with Jesus
half brother James
that's why Paul if you look there there
there's a passage in the Bible when Paul
said if anyone comes to you preaching
other than this gospel don't believe in
it why because he's already trying to
brainwash his followers to reject any
other gospels even if it's coming from
True followers of
Jesus you know so
so Christianity you believe the true
follows of Jesus they will be in
Paradise but people who are following
Christianity now following Jesus and to
go back to the main point here so how
can you believe God is
perfect and imperfect at the same
time it Go become
human you become human you become
imperfect or
not so so so God in the Bible said in
the with the word and the word with God
and the word became flesh so it became
something became languish it became
something if it became something to
become something that can now change you
have to change your nature because you
cannot become human with still have good
nature you're not human anymore human
have they have the special attrib
attributes which distinguish them from
animals and God he has a perfect
attribute which differentiate him from
the creation so how God who is uncreated
became
created doesn't make any sense that's
why you know you look
Islam Islam goes around our sound
reasoning and our our sound natural
vation there's only one God based upon
God's wisdom based upon his Mercy based
upon his Justice s CH people
us Jesus one of them Moses one of them
Abraham one of them ish one of them
Isaac Noah abrah the last of the
Muhammad he sent them to us to teach us
how to worship him if I was alive at the
time of Jesus the only way set my life
to follow Jesus at that time follow
Jesus I was alive at the time of Moses
in order for me to be successful I have
to follow Moses now the last prophet is
Muhammad when you become a Muslim you
losing no Jesus like I said you believe
in Jesus the way that Jesus the mighty
messenger the true Messiah want believe
in him let me
ask what was the belief of
Abraham what was
Abraham huh God is one Islam is Arabic
terminology if you do translate into
English mean to submit yourself to God
according to God's teaching so Abraham
submit to God is only one God and follow
God's teaching so we say he was a Muslim
that's why I mean Islam Abraham was not
Christian he was not a Jew Judaism came
after came based upon Judah the son of
Jacob the son of Isaac the son of abrah
okay likewise even Jesus what was belief
system what did he believe he believe
was he a Christian no was I Christian to
follow Christ and Paul call you
Christian okay Jesus never called his
followers Christians so
now that's why in the Quran tells us
that all the prophets and Messengers
were Muslims doesn't mean they following
Prophet Muhammad it means they submit
themselves to God according to God's
teaching you see what I'm saying so what
can choose from if you don't mind
asking so again when you look to uh you
know Israelite are you you Israelite you
know Israelite I mean even Jesus came
for the
Israelites when the canite woman in uh I
believe in Matthew yes
MTH Matthew when the canite woman came
to him seeking his help he rebuked her
she was in desperate need I don't
believe that story by the way but that's
what the Bible says so
he when his followers told him to help
her she had a problem with her daughter
her daughter she was possessed by demon
he said I should not give a breath to
the little dogs cuz he said I have been
only sent to the
house sheep of Israel not to you not to
the Arabs not to the LW sheep of Israel
that's why Prophet Muhammad was sent to
everyone you know but Jesus was sent to
Israelites okay so there there's many
problems with with Christianity the mod
Christianity as for Jesus teaching what
he came with is
perfect we believe Jesus to be Messiah
true Messiah you know we believe he was
a mighty messenger but we don't believe
you with God or the Son of God Allah
said the meaning of the verse Allah said
they claim Allah as a son you have come
with the most evil
statement Allah Allah goes on say is not
benefitting for the most benefit to have
son because to son is human nature you
want to pass on your inheritance to him
or to her and so on that's not God's
nature to have children you know so what
do you think so
far does it make sense about
Jesus yeah no no study I'm not tell you
to convert right now don't worry like
study time some people do become Muslim
straight to but you can study we have
LIF here you can read around this
area we we are here every Friday if you
have any questions you are no more than
welcome to come and ask uh questions
okay but uh like you know we uh want
good for mankind okay and uh when you
look at what's happening to the world
right now you know one of the miracles
of Islam was shows us that Prophet
Muhammad
with a true Messenger of
Allah the legislation he came with the
legislation he came with is perfect for
our life for example Islam came to
preserve five things okay Islam came to
Islam came to preserve the True Religion
that's why Islam will allow to pray to
any created thing that's why the Oneness
of God is very important and following
the true religion is very important
important secondly Islam came to
preserve intellect that's why alcohol
and drugs is forbidden third the Islam
came to protect wealth that's why
interest and gambling is
forbidden likewise Islam came to protect
family lineage that's why adultery and
fornication is forbidden lastly Islam
came to preserve people's life that's
why killing people unjustly committing
suicide is forbidden so these five
things if we do them we have good
Society the opposite is alcohol alcoh is
for us individually and collectively
even a small amount of alcoh is very bad
for you the scientists came to agreement
even a small amount of alcohol is not
safe in the Christianity you allow Al
whyne you believe is Jesus blood okay
likewise when it come to interest
interest destroy
s d
likewise fornication adultery likewise
okay and the most evil thing is we need
turn away from the True Religion the
true God so this five things will
destroy our societies what we see we see
this vir is been glamorized being
propagated being glorified alcohol drugs
delling interest and what distinguish
Islam from other religion cuz you might
tell me yes even other religions they
prohibit uh drugs and so on but it's not
prohibition Islam
has which is a law for the criminals
there deterent law that if you commit
this crime you will face his
punishment because human being will not
stay away from crimes and evil things
except by way of punishment that's why
we see everywhere in UK CCTV
operation Operation you see
psychologically they came to know humans
in order for them to to deter them from
any crimes you have to let them know
there is consequences for their crimes
so they've been washed Subhan Allah so
so these five things been glorified by
who those who have in power that's why
majority of times those who have very H
Islam are those in power because are
making the money from these evil vices
from gambling interest Banks uh call
prostitution and all of these crazy
things porn and so on that's why because
they have a lot of money money they
utilize the mainstream media to make
Islam look bad even though Islam is good
for us individually and collectively the
question should ask youself sister how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago Prophet
Muhammad was able to come with this
detailed a perfect way of life he
couldn't read and write we have these
politicians around the world smed in the
best universities around the world yet
they cannot resolve the problems you are
facing for example knif crimes
young boys like the age of 15 14
carrying a big knife why because they
know if they're going to stop someone
they're going to go prison prison here
has been outside I'm not saying go
prison by the way yeah but literally you
have when outside you don't have no me
three times a day in prison you have a
meal three times a day in prison you
have PlayStation 2 I don't know what
PlayStation Now what number is it now
you have you go to gym you have free
education Everybody's Free there and you
don't pay no rent but Islam
someone carrying knives there's a severe
punishment you see people now see
children carrying knives
stoping each other for po killing but if
you kill someone you be killed and you
put in ch square and establish the law
upon him you see how many children will
be scared to commit the crime
now when I was in prison 2005 we never
had social media now they they got
social media glam iing their lifestyle
the crime is crazy subh it's mad how
they glamorizing it like the guy singing
about it being happy about it Subhan
Allah that's why Islam is a perfect way
of life because capitalism is based upon
making money even from the suffer of the
people again Islam will not allow
singers who glorifies crimes and and and
and and evil things to give them
platforms uh to to propagate
their evil
things you're a singer should not be no
no you should be someone should speak to
you give advice you cannot ENT you canot
how you entrust youth with someone who
glorifies evil life or crime
lifestyle again makes money see that's
what Islam Allah when he legislate
something there is no bias involved no
evil desire involved cuz Allah wants
good for his creation but when human
beings legislate things they have B
within them they have evil desires
within them you know so subh Allah
that's why many people goes back to the
sh which is Divine Law many people
English people or French they get scared
of this
word but they don't
know is there to cause harm to people
rather is there to protect innocent and
to deal with the
criminals but that's why I I said those
who hate Shar law either ignorant or
themselves are
criminals you understand what do you
think what I said so far because I don't
want to keep talking if you have any
question or you think I said something
wrong your to
ask
yeah yeah
yeah of course he's
just is in the
Bible in the Old Testament the cuz
remember Jesus never had authority to
establish but Moses had authority to so
doesn't make any
sense because Jesus and and John his
cousin they were live under who under
the Roman Empire you know so he he
didn't have the power to
establish by Prophet Moses that's why
the Shar in the Bible sh is just of
course from
God so that's why like I said to you for
example if you kill someone you're not
going to put in prison Shar you'll be
Ked Shar gives choices to the the person
the family either you forgive which is
good as well so you look at the person
maybe he killed my brother by mistake
maybe he was very angry and he regreted
so if I forgive him I Allah teach us to
forgive as well but if this man is known
to Comm cries they forgiven him is going
to allow him to do more cries so the
comes we have to set him as an example
for the other criminals like you know
look to how good for our psychological
thinking imagine you have a child and
your neighbor commits crime and he goes
to prison here like I said your prison
is very good you know you come out a
healthy person he was skinny this
neighbor you know he was very skinny he
went in he came out looking good healthy
you're
tring go want prison prison is good he
was looking like a dead person looking
good but if he steal something Comm
crime who deserves capital punishment
for example is if you steal something
tomato or onion no you see something
which is valuable okay then in Islam
your hand should be cut off so if your
child see someone's hand be cut off said
ah because he stole something that's why
I don't want to steal I don't want to
lose my hand
you understand so psychically he's going
to be scared to commit crime you know
that's why no one knows in how to deter
the criminals like the one who created
mankind that's what in the Bible theate
killing
the in the Bible the Old Testament
no not a good question rather if imagine
I want to do evil thing then I fight
against it I get reward you know Allah
will not judge me for just having a
thought Allah will not judge me for just
having desires I about every
sa you know so I I do fight against my
evil desires my evil thoughts then I'll
be rewarded by
Allah yeah because that's what I'm
saying some people that they will not
leave sin set by punishment that's
reality so that's what Allah put the
punishment that's why they
say that's why one of our
leaders he said
Allah will remove evil things for the
leader that which does not be removed by
the Quran because Quran is G admonish by
the leader Allah gave him the
authority that some people they will
never leave evil except by establishing
the Capal punishment upon them this is
the reality you know so if he left the
sin because he SC of the punishment of
Allah he SC to the he will not be
rewarded but if he leaves it off because
he's scared of Allah and he loves Allah
not just scared of Allah but he love
Allah as well how how I'm going to
disobey someone who took care of me all
my life who bless me with his blessings
with his favors so stay away from this
of course no one is perfect all of us
into mistakes Disobedience that's to
Allah one of his beautiful
names the most beneficent full of Mercy
you know Allah the most generous the W
the all loving you know the most loving
the one who has perfect attri of love
you know the one who over pardon you
know but also Allah is just
like the almighty you know there certain
people if you give them ad they will
stay with some people accept punishment
from the leader I want to I'm to make
myself clear I'm not saying like this
evil sex within Islam which Islam is
free from their teaching they come here
says we want to take over the government
no sh has two meaning in general which
is worshiping God the Lord taking care
of your neighbors calling people to this
of Shar or the capital punishment which
is only the should be carried out by the
government you understand like you know
this evil say they go to to the
parliament say we going to take over the
parliament that's Islam
teaching now the question do I want sh
law for this country I want good for
this country but how they establish Shar
mean the which is implementing Muslims
so first I want this country to become
Muslim I want for them without fighting
them with a good way in a peaceful
manner because I want good for them I
believe Islam is good for me so I do a
respectful way without forcing them is
TE even they become Muslim of course
what you dictate if you believe in God
he is the creator of everything as a
ackowledge dictate you should follow his
law you see so because I something to
Muslims you sh this country if they say
yes the people are watching from the
non-muslims they think he wants to kill
us he wants to force a non-muslim woman
to a no that's not misunder
understanding which the media has been
pushing media based upon the evil
SE other people this
misunderstanding but if I I want to
become Muslim and follow God's law of
course CU I want good for them and I
believe that it's good for mankind in
every place and every
time is that CLE you have any other
question
like
yeah but Bas of like God is the just
correct is the all just ultimate just so
how come the question I'm going to you
is part of my answer how come God gave
the law to be implemented by Moses and
his and the rabbis that's Old
Testament because God lit is going to
come impl the law to you God gave you
the to follow for with authority you
understand yeah so for the authority to
implement that law and that is part of
your Justice and it show us that if you
want to be just amongst your soul God
gave us a law to follow you see that's
why you know Shar is based upon Justice
and wisdom and Mercy Mercy for the
innocent ones and also for the criminals
because when you receive the punishment
in this life God
will that will be protection for you and
get the punishment of the here after
which is way way worse you know so when
he rece
sorry no sh does implement Muslims
rather Islam to show you they talk about
tolerance okay Islamic sh country the
Christians they have their own
Court except if they did something which
involve within the country or they want
to Ru by Isam yes app to them but
generally speaking the app to for examp
how Christian should other Muslims or
for example other Islamic l so that's
why islamically speaking in and Islamic
sh the Christian they will have their
own Court they will have they appoint
leader among them and the Muslim leader
will say okay this is going to be your
judge you're happy with him that's why
historically speaking many Christian
countries open their gate for the
Muslims in Spain now they found out many
manuscripts back days when the Muslim
came to Spain they open cities for the
Muslims cu the Christians were
oppressing them like in Egypt the C were
been oppressed by the the Romans
Christians you see came they open their
gate for the the Muslims and they saw
the Muslim as their
saviors you see what I'm saying even the
Jewish people likewise in Spain where
you know about uh uh Inquisition Court
Inquisition Court occurred in the year
1492 by the Christians Catholic chran CH
in Spain Spain and Portugal when the
Christians took over Andalusia and they
start killing the Muslims forcing the
Jewish people and the Muslims to become
a Christian or they will kill them a lot
of Jewish people fled to Muslim
countries to Algeria to Morocco to belg
Belgium to to to Egypt to Tunisia to
Turkey you
know cuz they knew that's where
alhamdulillah
so that doesn't mean there was no Muslim
leaders or commit crime against
Christians or Jewish people they was
against Islamic teachers so I'm every
Muslim leader for the history was good
no they were evil even against the own
people okay
so that's why you know that's why sister
notice the Western world has turned away
from Christianity cuz see Christians is
about being church love God love
everyone that's
it no Islam is not Islam is not only for
uh uh uh worshipers for priest for IM
Islam for the government too the
government have to Islam as well you
know Islam is not just for for for a
group of people Islam came from Allah
Allah is the Creator and the God and the
one deserves to be worshiped by
everyone that's why look how Islam is
spreading around the world the fastest
growing religion on the face of the
earth is Islam who's doing the job even
though there's many many barriers to
prevent accep Islam yet Islam is
spreaded in the Western World Allah
mentioned in the Quran that Islam was
spread because Western especially women
they Islam oppress women but majority of
revers in Britain are women they see the
true freedom is to become a servant of
to become a slave of the Creator not a
slave of your desires and Satan and
Society see the only religion that is
standing firm and strongly and EV agenda
that has been pushed by this secret
society is
Islam you know
po accepted they said there's no problem
with gay people so you can see you know
you can see Christianity keep
changing you welcome here this I'm going
to give you something which is very
important here Mage is very
thank you got that one yeah have this
one there's woman in Islam
is last here last week you com good keep
coming all right thank you very much for
talking